hi everybody welcome to the Reuben
report i'm dave rubin we have a crazy
breaking news jam-packed edition of the
show today there is so much stuff going
on in the world right now you know some
weeks not that much going on we gotta
pull a story out of our butts not this
week there is just a ton going on things
are changing as we speak so we're gonna
get right to it I've got two great
guests with me I've got miss Jackie
Geary and miss Vanessa Gomez and there
is so much to talk about a lot of Egypt
stuff but we're gonna start with Alec
Baldwin I have to do this story because
of everything that I've been tweeting so
we all know basically what happened he
he was at James Gandolfini's funeral a
reporter thought that his wife was
tweeting during the funeral which
actually turned out not to be true and
then Alec went on his latest Twitter it
I raid let's read them all right so from
the bottom up in chronological order I
want to I want all my followers and
beyond to straighten out this
little George stark George stark
was the the writer who tweeted that his
wife was tweeting my wife and I attend a
funeral to pay our respects to an old
friend and some toxic Brit writes this
trash I put my foot up your
ass George stark but I'm sure
you dig it too much I'm gonna find you
george stark you toxic little Queen and
I'm gonna you up ah truly a lovely
lovely fella all right so before we get
into I just want to say I ABS I'm a
comedian I'm a talk show host I believe
in free speech you can do whatever you
want you can say whatever you want short
of you know yelling fire in a movie
theater and basically threatening
violence which he pretty much did so I
would always be around the side of free
speech so I don't necessarily think that
that's what this is about ladies where
does this loon like howdy how are you so
rich and entitled to get whatever you
want all times and still so angry Jackie
oh I have no idea it's so depressing and
horrible and I love him why does he make
it so hard for us to love him well
that's possible yes comedic Lee and evil
let's check inside
listed as a human-like keep it together
man yeah how do you I really I have so
much trouble every time I read it look
like this sticking the foot up the ass
and let that's a breaking right that's
where it crosses it for me I can't I
can't let that go that's that's some
rage-filled hate right there is that the
part that makes it homophobic to you cuz
the toxic Queen part I could see you
could work your way out of it what you
tried to buy debug you tried to say me
was referring to refer to anybody as a
queen just somebody thinks that they're
better than some right so we'll get to
his apology in a second but is the is
the put the foot up your ass and enjoy d
that's the part that makes it more
homophobic I mean look I think this
isn't the first time that he's gone on a
tirade I mean this is not news at eleven
you know we know that alec is capable of
doing this but yes I definitely think
that that was the tweet that broke you
know the camel's back it's like it was
so unnecessary and it was it was visual
I mean much that's part of it you know
you did I have a picture in your head
and um and yeah you're right i mean i
think that that was the tweet that was
really the what put over the edge i
think if he had just tweeted maybe the
other things like you said I you know
I'm gonna f you up or I'm you know
that's trash it's not true what he said
I mean obviously he's defending his
pregnant wife so I wouldn't say that
people would think it's uncommon or
unfair to you know defend his wife but
definitely he went way over the line
right so let's say well let's look at
his apology and then we'll and then
we'll jump back in so here's what he
said the idea of me calling this guy a
queen and that being something that
people thought is homophobic a queen to
me has different meaning it's somebody
who's just above it doesn't have any
necessarily sexual connotations I know
women that act Queeny I know men that
are straight that act Queeny and I know
gay men that act Queeny it doesn't have
to be a definite sexual connotation or a
homophobic connotation to me those are
people who think that rules don't apply
to them this guy could blatantly lie I
mean blatantly lie about my life on the
internet and there are just no rules
that apply to him but that's outrageous
to me now the irony of this is that alec
baldwin is the one that thinks no rules
apply to him remember the phone on the
play
and that whole thing so even in that
apology he really didn't address what
we're all agreeing is the the more
egregious comment and the threat of
violence right just stop talking stop
talking you've done enough stop talking
don't try to invent your own dictionary
for what words mean in our society well
I think the term dick really just refers
to people know it's hard for Richard
what's your name immigrant and just what
how I see the word shut up stop talking
that's not an apology yeah do you guys
think that he's getting off on this
because he's a well-known liberal
activist he's obviously left-wing the
media loves and left-wing media loves
him blah blah blah and as Hilary Rosen
of former CNN correspondent said he
gives money to the right cause is she
was actually defending him and I know
where I've had her on my old siriusxm
show and I was sort of shocked at what
she was saying cuz basically she was
saying look he gives money to gay causes
so let him let him say whatever you want
is that acceptable no absolutely not
acceptable I'm incidentally I don't
think he wrote that apology that's like
two different people everyone so let's
just start there like that was
completely eloquent and and different
than the person who was writing the
tweets um but yeah I think that that
would be maybe a good excuse that he's
thinking oh I give money so I have the
right to do you know it doesn't matter
whether you give money or where they
said it doesn't mean it's okay yeah for
him to have said what he said it just
doesn't yeah now relating this to
everything that's going on with paula d
and i know they're not exactly the same
thing but we vote we have two public
figures who are both being well one
attacked and one let go by things that
they said one racial one homophobic is
this is the thing with Paula Deen is
this purely because she is a Southern
woman so there's this you know again
this is sort of the left-wing media or
the mainstream media they can easily
attack so a woman from the south when
it's related to a racial thing but it's
a lot Die seer to attack sort of one of
their own about about even something gay
despite all the good day stuff that's
gone on lately yeah I mean I think
that's where it gets so tricky is
because even myself just as a human
loving alec baldwin as an actor and all
of work he has done it's so hard for me
to be
get him when I read it again it helps
but I somebody had pointed out if he was
a conservative right and hadn't given to
all these causes and was a different
person it would be it would be
outrageous and people would be furious
right if sean hannity had said this i'm
pretty sure there would be riots outside
of fox news I ever want to defend sean
hannity would show you do baby no i know
it's so tricky yeah so the other thing
about I think two is that Paula Deen is
herself she plays herself she's not an
actor like Alec Baldwin is we don't see
her in any other way like we do Alec
Baldwin we think of him and we think of
the great roles how funny he is that
shows he's been on all that stuff so I
think that has a little bit to do with
it and absolutely the fact that he is
you know liberal obviously I don't think
that he's homophobic I really don't
genuinely as a person just if you
actually where that come from where does
that imagery comfy that he obviously the
guy has anger management issues to say
the least and I think that when he gets
angry he obviously doesn't think before
he speaks i mean we saw that look at the
rage that he did towards his own
daughter yeah do you know any means so
if if that was okay to do that an attack
his own daughter I mean anybody's game
and so I'm not saying it's you know
obviously I'm not condoning it or
anything like that but I think he just
has anger management issues and he says
things out of anger that maybe aren't
rooted and you know I think he loves his
daughter obviously but you hear that
voice mail and you would think different
yeah so I don't know but I really would
love if if his sponsors came out and
said something alright so we'll get the
capital one in a second but before that
do you think that that this is really
about a word because Paula Deen said the
N word which we universally know you
know you shouldn't say you shouldn't
think that whole thing now he didn't say
which is now becoming the new F
word but do you think if he had said
that that then would have at
least coalesced all the the gay groups
and glad not to have immediately
exonerate him if he had actually said
the word do you think that that might
have been you know instead it was this
imagery but not a word I like I was so
dumb that yeah it's it's kind of messed
up that in not using the word he kind of
skated by a little bit even though the
what he had texted about the foot is so
Rachel right so rage-filled and so much
worse but yeah somehow he was able to
skirt around it and word choices I don't
know how yeah yeah Mayfield two ways
about it I feel on one sense yes that's
obviously a hot-button word it's a
trigger word if you woulda used it I
think people would have come out a lot
stronger but the other thing is we have
to remember that Paula Deen she sort of
attacked a community people it was
wasn't one person it wasn't in defense
because she was provoked or anything
like that I think the difference is Alec
Baldwin though he messed up he was
provoked this person did write something
that was extremely slanderous and not
okay about his wife and is there
anything more disrespectful than that to
say that you read a funeral and you know
we're uplifting or tweeted about
smoothies or whatever it is they turned
out not to be trying not to be true so I
think people also take that into
consideration like you know Paula Deen
was using these racial slurs because she
wanted to throw a plantation party I
mean you know so I think it's that and
also unfortunately and I know that I'm
not going to be the the you know the
good guy on the panel to say but I think
unfortunately we're still in a nation
that people are more okay with gay slurs
and they are racial slurs and I wish
that weren't the case but I feel like we
still are on that right we're still on
that balance and that's the irony of the
whole thing because we had all this
great stuff happened with DOMA and then
this is happening at the exact same time
which shows you that everything is a
long process but okay I want to talk
about capital one just to close this
thing so Alec Baldwin you know he does
those over-the-top commercials with
capital one capital one has not issued a
statement they've actually ignored
dozens of my personal tweets and they've
ignored thousands and thousands of other
people's tweets and emails and comments
and I know people from Forbes magazine
and others have been trying to reach out
to them to comment but they've ignored
everybody which may be to Vanessa's
point that you still can say things
about gay people and companies don't
have to do anything I actually called
capital one a couple times they hung up
on me twice the third time the rep said
that he was on vacation so he didn't
know what was going on and that they
couldn't get me in touch with anyone
else so I paid off the tiny bit that I
have left on my capital and credit card
and will no longer be using it and
what'll something right it's a little
yeah my $25 credit limit with you people
hello discover card I'm on my way yeah
but ok so then final thought on this do
you think it's just ridiculous the
capital one doesn't have to just all I
wanted them to I didn't want them to
fire him I don't think people should be
but that they want to say anything they
haven't felt any pressure to say
anything is that is that a bigger
problem here than almost the initial
though they're not recognizing that he
did anything wrong I think that's maybe
what bothers you that they should come
out and say either one way or the other
we support him yeah stand by him or
we're gonna fight him whatever but they
need to say something because something
was done wrong and I'm not saying it she
loses all her cookbooks the TV
everything except for her magazine I
think yeah it is societal I think if it
was nineteen sixty-two and somebody used
the n-word like Paula Deen nobody would
comment on it either and everybody would
be like well okay you know and just and
just you know yeah and I think hopefully
in 40 years nobody will be able to get
away with anything like that again I
think a perfect ending to a bizarre
topic alright so now we are going to
move on to some breaking news because
Egypt right this very second within the
last 20 minutes it was announced that
the military coup is underway Mohammad
Morsi who is the Muslim Brotherhood
candidate who a president who was
elected democratically after Mubarak
well you know was let go after 30 years
he is now on his way out so any of this
could change within the hour that it
takes for us to post this there's so
many ways we can start this thing and
it's a really really big topic that
they've basically been ignoring in the
news but so first what how do Americans
you have should Americans even feel
about this because there's a feeling in
America I think that we just should have
nothing to do with the world anymore
like we got so many problems at home
that we can't worry about this is that
is that as a bad route to take for
America I feel like we have to worry to
some degree but it's so tricky and I
think Obama has had such a tough time
knowing how much to say how much to do
and I think he did you know sort of miss
uh he came in a little late in that when
the Muslim Brotherhood started after
they came into power doing all these
things were that we're not
exactly correct women's rights out the
window yeah they weren't he wasn't
really he wasn't speaking up enough in
time but then there is the whole debate
it's this is not our country these are
not our people why do we as Americans
say well we are in charge of everything
and we're sort of big brother and we
always get to have a say and yeah
ironically not our country we gave the
Muslim Brotherhood 1.3 billion dollars
last month I'm pretty sure perhaps it
could be used for better fun what do you
think what do you think Americans post
should our involvement be nothing are we
supposed to take a side do up what side
are we on do you know that you know what
I think we're on our own time you know
as usual um I think that we're always
involved in any international you know
affairs or disputes or anything I think
that's kind of what we're known for why
we're loved and while we're hated you
know to be quite honest and rose
sticking our nose in someone else's
where the Wendy Williams of the world in
a second I Rosen 7s is it not you do ND
um no but seriously it's it's it's a
hard line to walk like you said it's a
hard balance you don't want to be over
involved you don't want to be under
involved obviously we care what's going
on there and we have completely
different democracy even after they
brought in this new electoral votes all
that it still turned out to be the same
ending unfortunately these people took a
chance they thought that they were
changing the Constitution they thought
they were changing the way the
oppression all of that and it as it
turned out they had a guy that was worse
than the last guy they just kicked out
right now is all of that just part of
democracies growing pains because it
seems to me they had Mubarak for 30
years nobody really liked and they were
really free but at least he kept some
sort of order right then they they've
had democracy and that's the irony it's
like what are we supposed to do now
right because they did democratically
elect this guy and Obama said a lot of
nice things about this guy and military
coozer are not comfortable things for
Americans to really wrap their heads
around I think and rightly so yeah you
know it's yes the Egyptians have every
right to be angry and to be protesting
and this man should not be in office and
yet military kuz that's some intense
stuff right is there any that's the
thing it's like no matter what happens
so you go from a dictator to a
democratically elected guy who's no good
to know a military coup we have no
reason is the military son Lincoln
really all right women's rights for
every
right to give me super fair alyssa clip
in mind i feel like they took one giant
step forward and then like 10 steps back
because typically egypt has always been
ruled either by an old military
commander someone you know somebody do
the military this is sort of the first
time and they thought oh my god this is
great we're finally you know gonna have
some freedoms and and things like that
and i think that this guy you know it
was bait and switch to be honest I mean
if I'm gonna put this in a pinch money
metaphor it's like you know you're
dating a girl then she's hot she's got
long hair just got the lashes in the
nails and then you take her home and you
wake up the next morning and she's bald
and crazy you know it's just like wait a
minute like who is you know
misrepresentation so um so yeah you know
I think that right now the role that
we're taking it's it's we're covering it
we have our opinions on it obviously
there at the end of the day it's there
it's their land and they're gonna do
what they want to do I'm with you on
this crazy metaphor though because I was
watching a YouTube clip from last year
with Christiane Amanpour from CNN
interviewing Morsi and he's going on and
on about how much he loves democracy and
freedom and women's rights in cuz you
yes great guy great guy that's what I
mean obviously it was totally bait and
switch and I mean we should be calling
this catfish you know it's like he's
letting himself as one thing you show up
and you're like where's the person that
I whatever here I'm so obviously he had
an agenda he's probably Muslim
Brotherhood I mean that is pretty you
know cut and dry and fortunately man
under Mubarak again not defending move
arc but this was a group that was banned
for being so extreme under right so
better the devil you know than the devil
you don't they say perfect and I think
that that yeah well any now all right so
last point on this is there some every
time I when I'm watching this now I keep
thinking this is like watching a reality
TV version of the Ten Commandments
that's what this feels like to me
doesn't it I feel like Charlton Heston's
gonna walk out and go let my people go
yeah but is that out but do we need
those things do you need those things to
frame it like I feel like that's a
simple way to frame it you know to me
like there's this group of people like
like everyone watch the Ten Commandments
is this group of people that wants to be
free and fair OH morsi's not letting
them be free and now all hows about
break loose yeah it's always easier to
be like let the people speak and be free
and absolutely and that's where my heart
is and I think that's where so many
American cards because we are you know
your frame we're sitting like 14 million
people are out there protesting and 13
million voted more CN right so it but at
the same time it's obviously so much
more complex and that's why I mean it's
the first time in history where the
people are actually for the military lab
before it was like they were against it
now they're like a row yeah wrong name
they know no jumping on tanks but um but
yeah I think it's it's unfolding as we
speak and we'll see how it goes and you
know hopefully hopefully it'll be good
and and it turns out well for them stop
talking on TV all right well I think I
think we gave you as insightful if not
more than anything you're going to see
on CNN all week and that brings me to
the next topic because I've been just
beyond over the top disappointed and I
guess I shouldn't even be shocked at
this point with CNN's coverage of this
whole thing one of the oldest
civilizations in the world is having the
biggest protests in human history and
instead CNN is showing wall-to-wall or
as they call it gavel to gavel that's
what Ashleigh Banfield said coverage of
the George Zimmerman trial now I'm not
diminishing the importance of the George
Zimmerman trial it is very important
there are all kinds of racial issues we
still have to deal with this country but
showing any trial just hours of trial
minutia is just pure pure drivel
especially when important things are
going on should I just get off my thing
with CNN a i see i have a thing where I
want them to be good because Fox is
awful on ray MSNBC is awful the other
way so I want and that's why I love
working here at the Young Turk because
we're doing that online but I still want
there to be yeah I want there to be
someone giving us actual news am I just
a crazy dreamer no I think CNN is sadly
pandering to the masses in the sense of
what we were just discussing I don't
think America knows what to think about
Egypt I think they're a little scared
and don't really know what to think or
say or do about it so it's so much
easier to just zone out to the
Zimmerman's well I die and it's
it's disappointing it's really
disappointed shouldn't CNN be the one
that's showing it to us so that we were
they should I mean look I'm gonna say
something that's not gonna go over well
it's gonna go over like a fart in church
to be honest but it's below that way the
truth is I'm you know I say it like I
mean it um I don't think Americans first
of all names are so much harder to
pronounce can I just say you know um
it's sad that we don't care as much as
that we're so obsessed with these trials
i mean oj simpson Casey Anthony Jodi
arias Amanda Knox you know now this is
the new George Zimmerman we're fixated
on these on these trials and it's
happening on our own Shores you know
it's not something that's over there and
the other thing is I think that we can
everyone had a verdict I think before
the trial even begun so everyone is just
looking to have their verdict backed up
by the evidence by by the witnesses by
all of that it's great water cooler talk
you know it's easier to talk about that
and you can relate because ultimately we
can put ourselves in that shoe what
would you have done if you had seen it
we can't really put ourselves in the
shoes of the Egyptians because we don't
live like that that's not our reality
well interesting i want to show just an
image of CNN what they've been doing so
they're showing Zimmerman all the time
and sometimes they're skyping people in
that box on the left and they're showing
the trial and Egypt is getting a tiny
you know right picture in picture box uh
live protest bill in Egypt it's actually
changed at some point today was watching
now which is bizarre because it's like
that say well we're watching but you
really should be watching but we're not
gonna have you people watching it I mean
ratings but we'll want to see mm but do
people do that my question is this do
people really I think we just keep
feeding them crap and they just keep
ingesting it do they really want to see
these trials do you want to see these
Charles really want to see these trials
but yeah I found it all over the
television last night and since it's
everywhere you get sucked in and you
start watching and you would expect more
from CNN sadly you would Nancy Grace
sure all day long wall-to-wall but not
CNN when so much is happening in Egypt
it would be different if nothing was
going on this week at all but yeah I
think since it's forced down our throats
then we go oh interesting well maybe
those lacerations aren't you know
conducive with
everything oh right is there anything
more irrelevant really than hour after
hour of trial coverage again I'm not
diminishing the importance of the trial
but but the minutiae of what goes on in
a trial and the back-and-forth drivel
and the questioning and the and that we
know that most whatever gets decided he
and probably has nothing to do with the
truth it is only doing who manipulated
it better like can you think of anything
that would be more irrelevant for five
hours in a row to show that a trial what
would be more driveling watching paint
dry I don't know yeah um and I think
like I said I I think part of it is
where it's driven down our throats I
think part of it is that's what we want
we are responding to them to these
stories by giving our ratings and tuning
in and that's the problem they wouldn't
be doing this it would be no supply
without demanding I mean it's a chicken
and egg situation drama people love
drama if they're not so proper taking so
let's watch yeah right well
interestingly yesterday I was on Twitter
goin crazy about this and I I tweeted at
CNN's Jake Tapper who was on air at the
time and I said Jake do you on your own
show that has your name on it do you
even decide what story was first cuz
they did literally 12 minutes of
Zimmerman and then they did about a
minute on Egypt and he tweeted at me
during the commercial break and he said
it depends what's happening live which I
thought was bizarre because uh that's
there there are a million people and
Jack like Jake but it was an odd
response anyway this whole Egypt thing
is going to keep going for a long long
time and hopefully right now if you were
to turn on any other network they're
doing a better job and I hope that they
will continue to do so all right so this
next story I'm this is just beyond
disturbing and before we even get to it
we're going to show some video in a
second that is extremely extremely
graphic so if you want to pause or look
away for a little bit or something so
you probably heard about this already
because this video is going viral a man
in Hawthorne California there was a
police incident and a bunch of people
were outside videotaping some cop cars
and the police officers and
well now we're going to show it but
really it is quite graphic so let's take
a look went to the ground oh that's for
the crown I like the dies the guard
watching home a nice and dark comes on
extra dog is a dog house come at the
dock hours
oh sure sorry and I'll make you some
artichoke oh hey watch it watch it
don't miss
okay that does not get easier to watch
no matter how many times I've watched it
at this point all right so it's unclear
exactly why the man was being arrested
it's not illegal to videotape police
officers while there there's an incident
it seemed bizarre that they immediately
handcuffed him just like that and then
the guy had the dog out he actually put
the dog in the car the dog jumped out of
the window so it wasn't like he was
trying to SiC the dog on the cops and
then as you saw the cop shot the dog
several times okay there's so many
levels with this story involving so many
things so I actually I'm just gonna
where do you want to start with this one
Vanessa I mean where do we start if you
see earlier in the video first of all I
don't even know why the man was arrested
he was just right supposed to be about
he wouldn't turn off the radio he had a
new dance at best and best turn down the
music that's supposedly what it was but
he did turn it off when he put the dog
in the car and they just did walk right
up to him and immediately in reston ok
so we're already off to a bit of a
sketchy start I mean look I think if you
unfortunately I did see the video a few
times and I and I really paid close
attention to the dog's behavior um yes
he responded as any dog by the way my
dog would respond it the exact same way
if I've got five six people in all black
I know manhandling me doesn't know the
situation the owners handcuffed so
there's no way for him to you know tell
the dog to calm down or grab the dog you
can see him trying to command the dog
and tell you know the dog does obviously
doesn't know English so he's not going
to respond to just the owners commands
and what I want to know is you know look
I look I love police I'm not like anti
you know I think they're amazing I think
they put their life on the line to
protect and serve so let me just put
that out there right now but in my
personal opinion as a citizen I think
that deadly force should be the last
resort and I feel like in this video it
was the first resort yeah do you know
what I mean I think that if indeed this
officer was threatened you know
physically or felt like he was
physically at risk then there were a lot
of other options that should have
happened that could have happened before
ultimately going to shooting
he had pepper sprayed the dog why
couldn't he have tried to contain the
dog even with his leg even with what I
mean there's five six officers if he
were there by himself arresting somebody
just with the dog and the dog was
inviting you know that's a different
circumstance but it wasn't there were
like six cop cars a SWAT car I mean I'm
ready for Will Smith to walk out of the
house with the AK like look like a movie
yeah I mean I talked about having backup
so right so I'm with you on this because
there are many other options and it's
very easy for us all to always gang up
on the police and if you look at all the
comments on YouTube yes everyone's
immediately attack me please there
clearly was some level of threat but are
you on board this idea that there were
other options available or that it just
escalated to quickly that no there
wasn't even a moment of really trying to
corral the dog in any other way and
should a cop me put have to deal with
that or did he I mean I heard an account
of it before I watched the video and I'm
glad as horrible as it is that I watched
the video because it does escalate
quickly and the dog isn't at fault than
the owner isn't at fault of course he
left the windows down because it was a
million degrees on Sunday and I can see
the pod officer got scared and reacted
really stupidly and it's so upsetting um
it comes down to pepper spray something
do something else other than shoot it
four times yeah and this is also show
how humans you know they look I it seems
to me that there was some racial element
going on there because the the the man
himself seemed to be egging on the
police a little bit in the way he would
Seattle like a little bounce in his step
of his videos having them and then they
were walking hood and there seemed to be
just some sort of like he's dealt with
police in this in this element before
but then look who pays at the end of the
day was the innocent animal and and
maybe the cop will now pay I mean look
if you if you take a really close look
at the video as unfortunately I did the
dog retreats many times I mean he'll
start to go but then he'll come back on
the curb and if you see right before he
was shot the cop actually lunged towards
the dog before he went up to finally try
and bite him and I think that's not okay
you know so like I said deadly force
should be in my opinion the last resort
and I feel like in this situation it was
the first resort and I think that it was
a bad judgment and
is you know in that moment I don't know
if that's just under training I don't
know if it's just maybe this guy's
trigger-happy abused abuse of power I
mean four times to shoot an animal you
know maybe even if you just shot him
once as like a reaction or he could say
I didn't even realize what happened but
four times yeah I mean it's it's really
just bizarre that everyone knows they're
being look they went into this knowing
that they were being recorded already
because the guy was recording them dude
does that make it even weirder that
these things can still happen when
everyone knows they're being recorded
all the time yeah you would think you
would think they would dial it down or
have some sense of this apparently this
man showed up and started videotaping
because he'd had civil rights violations
by the police and hawthorne in the past
there was even something i heard that
maybe it was the same officer that had
roughed him up there's a couple
completely who knows um but you would
think then especially if these officers
recognize this guy and it's being
videotaped by so many people that there
would be some sense of decorum don't
shoot a dog yeah don't shoot a dog all
right well I mean I think clearly we're
all on the same page here and it is not
an easy situation and I have certainly
have empathy for the officer to because
it's a bad situation he got put in but I
guess this would be a good time to jump
on my soapbox and tell you adopt a dog
instead of buying your dog we are all
dog adopters here we discovered before
the show and there are so many great
dogs that are ready to be adopted and
and the mills are killing it's a whole
other thing we'll do that on another
show all right let's leave it there all
right next up it was a huge week for the
the Supreme Court and the gays as we
call them now DOMA was struck down prop
8 is going back to the States so a lot
of good stuff happened for marriage
equality and it got me thinking about
how television and media influences our
ability to change and how it affects
society and then it had me thinking
particularly about one clip from my
favorite all-time show The Golden Girls
about marriage equality this so this is
a golden girls clip I believe this is
season 7 1992 take a look
Blanche I've been thinking about Clayton
and Doug and I have a question well why
do men have nipples
I have no idea you think it's because
God has a sense of humor and this and
this uptight is the rest of us it's
easier for you to say that Sophia it's
not your brother who's getting married
to a man oh look i can accept the fact
that he's gay but why does he have to
slip a ring on this guy's fingers of the
whole world will know why did you marry
George we loved each other we wanted to
make a lifetime commitment wanted
everybody to know that's what Doug and
Clayton want to everyone wants someone
to grow old with and shouldn't everyone
have that chance what Sofia I think I
see what you're getting there I don't
think you do Blanche would you marry me
thank you Susie I need to go talk to
them fine but I'll need an answer I'm
not gonna wait for you forever all right
i love that clip for so many reasons
first off funny funny funny and also it
was telling truth and again this is 20
some odd years ago and they were telling
and this was in florida gay marriage
certainly wasn't legal 22 years ago far
that's not legal now so I think this
brings us to an interesting topic which
is how much does this stuff actually
transe you know make its way into
reality because on one hand you can look
at this and go well that's amazing they
did that 22 years ago but it took it
still took 22 years to get this far so
should we be inspired by these these
things that come out of pop culture so I
think it's an important part of the
process I think when we fall in love
with characters and we feel like they're
our own family our own friends then
after that investment when we see we're
so much more likely to hear what they
have to say when it's as funny and
wonderful as that and I think I think so
much did lead up to it I think will and
grace played a big role you know in the
early 2000s I think there were a lot of
shows the more it was represented on our
television sets the more i think the
country was able to empathize and
understand and get on board and i think
i it's it's a kind of a nice thing for
you know the comedy of the world for the
comedy for the comedy I mean listen
obviously i think it was fantastic it it
talked about a topic that wasn't really
talked about on television this is
before willing grace before modern
family our new normal or any of these
shows were in our living rooms where we
were normal already canceled right Wow
yeah it was very positive you know gay
role models on television that people
could you know really get behind and i
love that the Sophia who is the oldest
you know Cicely picture at 1910 you know
it's like she's educating the younger
generation if anything you would think
she would be the one that needed to be
you know educated so I love that um but
yeah it's like you said I mean it's any
time that we see other people doing
anything having
the opinion it always always always has
an effect on you because it makes you
think well what would I do or what would
I you know see or what would I think
well I think that okay so I'm with you
guys a hundred percent so far and stuff
like that has a huge powerful impactful
you know society montery however is
there is this a bit of a slippery slope
because like when all these politicians
jump on TV and they always say well
there's too much gun violence and TV and
video games and that's why people are
shooting each other so does it run both
ways that we get good images that are
changes for the good but bad images of
changes red I'm not a personal believer
that video games cause violence because
otherwise I'd be an Italian plumber
eating mushrooms jumping on Turtles but
you know to me like does it do does it
go both ways if the good stuff is good
for us is the bad stuff equally as bad I
think it's easier to say that yeah
absolutely you got to take you know you
gotta take a sugar with your with your
salt and if you're gonna stand on one
side you got kind of got to stand on it
you know for both sides but I think part
of it and this is the point that I
totally completely ruin our day I'm just
killing time thank you i appreciate that
is um I think in 1992 I think there was
still a lot of people who hadn't come
out yet and so I think there was a lot
of areas of the world but certainly even
just our nation where people didn't
really know that many gay people not
that they maybe didn't know that they
were gay or maybe it wasn't accepted and
so showing it on television is like
showing them it's like they know
somebody I know cam you know even if in
their personal life they don't know
somebody you know who's gay or who's out
there like oh that's so cool and that
builds you know tolerance and all of
that but you're right I don't think look
I think environment has a little bit to
do with why people do things absolutely
i mean this guy that went in like he was
the Joker in Batman and shot up that I
mean do I think that he would have gone
that route if he hadn't seen the dark
night I don't know he probably had a
screw loose to begin with right I might
have just done it a different way
without a joker math right but to say
that it has no influence no I have to
say that I really do think it does have
an influence but I think you have to be
smart enough to be like okay this is a
game this is a movie this is not real or
whatever it is and hopefully when it's
something positive like you know I'm
tolerance people are like this is cool
yeah do you guys have any shows that
affected you in any specific way
anything that may be empowered you as
women or as comic personalities or
whatever it might be
mr. listen I will mix matching my socks
every day because of punky no see um
yeah like you know blossom and now we're
going to address I don't know if any of
them spoke to me personally but it was
as a kid you know you're hearing about
all these things that you are maybe
sheltered from and don't know about and
and therefore are enlightened by that
very special episode yeah i remember a
very special episode of growing pains
when they go to you know Kirk Cameron
and Mike Seaver goes to a party with
boner I know they named that kid like
some that was in immediate word name
this guy boy but uh you know and boner
goes off and does coke with you know a
bunch of other kids and my cousin and
they made it a very special and that
stuff does stick with you as a kid right
absolutely yes absolutely and that's a
lot easier way to do it than just like
on the news or somebody like pushing it
down your throat it's like they kind of
put it in entertainment and make it
softer and especially with golden girls
I mean that was a sick home they made it
funny they made it light-hearted it
wasn't something that was like tragic or
hushed or anything like that so kudos to
them I think gay for the girls yeah
great for the Golden Girls thank you for
being a friend I've had to say it
legally once in this exactly all right
one more for you prescription drug use
is off the charts bonkers right now
seventy percent of Americans are on
prescription drugs let's look at some
numbers okay seventy percent of is that
are on at least one so many of them are
on more than that and you know you have
to take your ambit of lie to supplement
your well a beaut trim and blah blah
blah that's a fifty percent increase
from 2007 to 2010 so it's probably
higher than that right now fifty percent
of Americans are on at least two
prescription drugs and twenty percent of
Americans are on five or more
prescription drugs twenty percent are on
five or more prescription drugs I'm not
going to ask either one of you
specifically how many prescription drugs
you are taking these numbers seem
horrific to me like this is maybe a
bigger problem that we have in America
than anything else at the moment and to
me it's so obvious where it's coming
from it's
a commercialization of it I mean there
really wasn't a way they've finally
figured out how to put them on
television with the smiley faces and the
dogs jumping and the happiness and
people are like oh great the requests
people are going into their doctors
saying hey I saw a commercial for this I
would like it please there was a little
cartoon chasing me I need a cloud I have
the cloud no so that's a and they I
think it's so funny that they don't air
those commercials on radio there's no
drug commercials on radio because they
don't work because there are no happy
fish that's that's an interesting point
so if you're in your car yes listening
to it you're still seeing trees or
people so your brain but if you see a
depressing class Oh Harry I never
thought creepy what do you think I think
I think a lot has to do with that I also
think in the study it says that a lot of
them are antidepressants and I think the
economy had a huge hand in that people
lost their homes people lost their jobs
people lost their lifestyle they lost
their nest egg the retirement so even
ordinary people that maybe would not
have been depressed or don't have
depression in their family or whatever
it is are now finding themselves down in
the dumps because of you know what has
happened but isn't that just part of
life what that 10 years ago or 20 years
ago certainly that was just part of life
and now because of the marketing machine
it's like oh I'm a little depressed like
I lost my job I need a totally
acceptable now I think before being
depressed was like you know everyone was
quiet and didn't want to admit it and it
was like the stigma that was on and I
think now people are like hey i need
help i need some you know whatever or
we're in the society of the internet
where we want immediate gratification
we're like push button getting results
you know so i think instead of like you
said like just getting over it or maybe
doing some meditation or some therapy
people like give me a pill give me a
pill what's gonna fix it i don't want to
go you know people know how to lose
weight they know how to how to work out
they know what they should and shouldn't
be eating you don't need a book to tell
you that you know six pieces of cake
before you go to sleep it's probably not
a good idea okay either way they want
right you here to here first ah either
way they want a pill that's going you
quick trim or whatever it is that's
gonna fix them right away so I think
it's the same thing and I think you know
with the internet they're going on there
and they're not only seen these
commercials but I mean I diagnose myself
all time I'm on WebMD and my god
sneaky you know cough or a jumper right
exactly and you were cancer to come up
here I am sweet every time i go on
whether be it makes me think of that
episode of the simpsons when they when
uh mr. burns goes to the clinic and they
tell him that he has absolutely every
disease known to man and but they're in
perfect balance so that he can't get
sick and that's what I feel like Ramon
I'm like I have everything right
hysterical pregnancy everything exactly
do you guys do you guys think that that
in these commercials because I do think
that's the root of this whole thing that
they should have to show you the side
effects not just list them because
literally about forty percent of the
commercials you're saying diarrhea
nausea possible suicide death mother but
they never show that instead it's a guy
in a field that he's running in someone
at your kids any gonna doing all this
amazing stuff but if they actually
showed you puking on the toilet and jump
and having a hanging yourself and maybe
jumping over do you think that that
might shoot that commercial yeah let's
do that funnier dying people you can
have that idea yes absolutely because
they're saying may cause prostate cancer
as the man is smiling and lovingly at
his spouse like sexual dysfunction right
you won't be able to get these people
they take viagra to get a boner then
they get depressed now they can't get a
boner then they take cialis because they
need a longer by cream the testosterone
cream where if you accidentally touch
your wife and with the cream on your
hands she will grow a beard so call your
doctor right okay she the one it'll put
hair on your head but if your wife
touches it it'll kill the unborn baby
and I yeah this is why people are on
five or more for sure yes because they
take one and the side effects of this
one they need three others and the side
effects of those they need you know and
it's a never-ending train in others need
sidebar to this so i was i don't really
like to fly and i went to a psychiatrist
to get xanax to fly and that was all I
wanted he told me that I have time shift
disorder what and that there was a new
pill that he wanted me to take and I
kept saying to my sweater god this is
true and I kept saying to him no no I
just want xanax I just want to be able
to pass out on the plan that's it he
wouldn't he literally would not let me
leave without a prescription for its I
took the prescription which I proceeded
to throw away but even his tape
dispenser on his desk was at head Sully
wasn't zoloft but it was something
singing I bought weed in my day I'm
gonna whisper this I bought and the weed
dealer has never been like but you want
the cloud me do he had some crack to do
what we do is like I decisively yeah so
it doesn't that show you the system is
just corporations and the doctors who
were I mean it's a payout it's a mess
it's a mess it's a mess and what is
timeshift disorder like she was mad yeah
there's oh god I don't ya being back to
the future they would have mentioned it
i'm saying is that was a real big he
could get back to nineteen eighty nine
um know exactly i think that has a lot
to do with it I mean look doctors are
it's a business at the end of the day
yes they want to help you yes you know
hopefully they're there for the right
reasons other than you know their
Bentley um but when it comes down to it
they are a freelance person they work
for themselves and these drug companies
are making a ton of money and they are
giving them incentives whether it be
perks gifts money checks kickbacks
whatever it is so obviously that doctor
was getting something for you know for
giving you that and make it making you
go and get that medication I don't think
he genuinely thought you needed it
because you would have just said look
time shifted that's not a disorder
that's a made-up imaginary thing
timeshift disorder all right well I hope
that we've inspired you a little bit and
not depressed you to have to go take the
pills you're on or go get a whole set of
new ones I want to thank Jackie Geary
fake Jackie Giri on the Twitter and
Vanessa gomez that's Vanessa m Gomez on
Twitter and joy for it so get out there
and have some funny get away from your
computer for a little bit and see what
happens okay
you